hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to quad but this isn't just
regular co-op oh no this is qwop that
has been hacked and you will see exactly
how it was hacked right now ish because
this one was hacked in the wrong
direction one the gravity has been
slightly lowered and it is impossible to
die and the reset button has been
disabled this is the ultimate version of
holy hell it's impossible to eat so one
once I'm sorry I didn't know that you
wanted to do a handstand right there one
it's impossible to run anyway in coop
two with the lowered gravity prefers to
swim like a fish as opposed to being oh
yeah this is exactly what I wanted to do
now the proper way to play co-op is to
alternate the W o and P I wasn't quite I
was on the wrong button not that I think
that even matters at this point so now I
seem to be trying to progress backwards
into the game that I cannot reset from
and I have to run so anyway a lot of
people wanted me to play co-op for a
while but I'm I thought that it's been
played out so how about I sit here and
flail for about 50 oh this is good I
like the panel kick technique that you
got going on here yeah yeah get back on
your feet yeah I did it okay now I can
beat my best record of 5.6 nah oh god
damn it you just got back on your feet
you douche mother of ok senior quaffing
Tintin qua ping land would rather be on
the Africa a crime dag I've seen people
beat this but I can't even get back on
my own two feet
ah we're just gonna calmly try different
button combinations to see if that works
we're gonna draw wait a minute you
almost had it
yeah okay
hey now okay extend or s wrong extend
that leap up there forward momentum is
the key to winning co-op okay
oh that was beautiful this is beautiful
you're a beautiful shining star look and
go oh my it still says I'm at point four
meters I don't know how that's gonna get
my god ass okay how did we get back up
on our feet
oh nice limbo but we're not playing that
game right now we're playing no no huh
you've done a complete flip you dick now
you're in the wrong okay you gotta flip
back now go ahead for you god damn it
you son of a donkey balls
yeah got it shove it fudge no oh you
almost had it
you almost had it you always had okay
now you completely lost it and you're
splaying your crotch for the entire
crowd to see beautiful bigger your feet
God ow you flipped in why god dammit you
son of a [ __ ] I really am NOT trying to
lose guys this is literally impossible
to go haha so you wanna get here when
you can plan afoot what a WOM what else
can you do I mean okay alright this is
how I got here before I planted the foot
it tucked it in as much as possible and
I goddamn it and you try to like squeeze
it oh you tried no because you look now
why are you telling why are you doing a
handstand right now or a heads god damn
it ah well this is my life now
trying to be cropping the old oh yes
well if I wanted to go backwards and
pretend that I was a swan I've got a
good impression going on right here
I don't even think I can win mostly
because it's all where did I go what I
don't even understand okay that's the
end you know what I'm not gonna subject
myself to ten whole minutes of this crap
I'm done me falling through the world
was this was a sign that I need not play
Noir
there it is qwop the hack version if you
want to play this there is no link you
can find it on your own and there's
multiple hack versions but this is the
worst by far so anyway there you have it
I played co-op are you all happy now
thanks for watching and as always I will
see you in the next